le vice-président fred hampton du
parti panthère noire de l'illinois
[Applaudissements]
répétez après moi
je suis
[Applaudissements]
vous regardez
[Musique]
18 mois pour la voiture volée
cinq ans pour avoir usurpé l'identité d'un officier fédéral
[Musique]
ou vous pouvez rentrer chez vous
les panthères noires forment une coalition arc-en-ciel
de frères et
soeurs opprimés de toutes les couleurs leur but est de
montrer la haine et d'inspirer la terreur
peut diriger un révolutionnaire mais vous
ne pouvez pas assassiner la révolution
et vous pouvez assassiner un combattant de la liberté mais
vous ne pouvez pas assassiner la liberté
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous